am i missing a tooth ah teeth truly the
fingernails of the head every human
being is born with every tooth that they
will ever have already secreted away in
different parts of their skull and the
cost of getting a replacement implanted
is enough to keep most people brushing
not so for these hollywood stars though
let's take a look at 16 performers who
busted up their teeth for a roll thank
you
number 16.
let's start ourselves off with one
that's hot off the presses while doing
press for the upcoming giant comedy
don't look up star jennifer lawrence
told reporters that she lost a tooth
early on in the shooting process see
many actors wear veneers artificial
ceramic overlays that give them whatever
level of messed up teeth they need for a
shoot which are normally tight fitting
and glued down over their regular teeth
you know i had a feeling so tight in
fact that when lawrence's veneers came
out during shooting they pulled one of
her actual teeth out with them and if
that's not enough to make you squirm she
couldn't even get it fixed saying and i
couldn't go to the dentist until the end
of the movie so i had to film most of
the movie toothless
number 15.
let's start ourselves off with one that
we probably shouldn't talk about fight
club was an instrumental part of brad
pitt's transition into a more seriously
regarded and versatile actor that's
right and pitt went all out to portray
the violent grungy and ultimately
imaginary tyler durden
he even went so far as to undergo dental
surgery and have chips knocked out of
his front teeth all the better to embody
the role of a bare-knuckle boxer the
first rule of fight club is
you do not talk about fight club
number 14.
something that we'll see a lot of on
this list is prosthetic teeth and
veneers a full or partial mouthful of
gnarly chompers the actors have
installed over their regular teeth like
caps
this is the route that christian bale
chose to go in the fighter playing a
drug-addicted boxer bale not only
dropped 70 pounds for the roll he
elected to have a custom mouth of broken
and decaying teeth glued down over his
regular teeth for the duration of
shooting
number 13
another thing that we'll probably hear a
lot on this video is the name gary
archer a dental lab technician by trade
archer has made a career out of building
custom prosthetics and veneers for some
of the biggest names in hollywood and
how did he get his start well maybe you
remember a little movie called mrs
doubtfire archer and actor robin
williams worked together to build a
custom set of loose-fitting dentures
that could drop out of william's mouth
for that iconic drinking gag
i'll be right back
i just have to reattach some little heat
number 12.
in 1994 jim carrey played the lead in a
whopping three films but we're not here
to chat about the mask or aceventure a
pet detective even if carrie wore those
gigantic dentures for the mask instead
let's take a look at dumb and dumber to
get ready for the roll carrie had a
previous bit of dental surgery reversed
removing a cap from one of his front
teeth to create lloyd's wild chipped up
grin
oh yeah
number eleven
shia labeouf has a reputation these days
as a guy who will do just about anything
for a role most of the time that means
putting on or losing some weight staying
locked up inside to lose a fan or
messing with your sleep schedule to
become nocturnal for a while
on fury la buff went a lot further to
create the illusion of being a soldier
who has gone through the horrors of
world war ii the actor had both of his
front teeth pulled
creating a huge gap in his smile that
had to be filled again after shooting
number 10
one of the most famous examples on this
list has to be johnny depp in the
pirates of the caribbean franchise to
help create the grimy scummy look of
captain jack sparrow depp opted to have
several of his teeth capped over with
gold during shooting giving himself the
look of a lifelong pirate whose
hard-living and constant rum drinking
has left him with a ruined set of pearly
yellows
number nine
singer-songwriter freddie mercury was
known for always going big as the front
man of queen big performances big energy
and well big teeth the performer
suffered from several additional teeth
at the back of his mouth which pushed
his normal teeth forward into a
substantial and instantly recognizable
overbite actor rami malik had to
recreate this effect for the film
bohemian rhapsody slotting in sizable
dentures and having to learn how to talk
and sing around his mouth being forced
into a new and uncomfortable shape
number eight
let's get old school for a minute and
talk about the horror classic the
haunted strangler as boris karloff's
character becomes increasingly possessed
by the ghost of a serial murderer he
takes on an increasingly grotesque and
corpse-like appearance to create this
look karloff removed his false teeth and
sucked in his cheeks to give his face a
sunken appearance
and his lips were partially wired shut
to give him a constant sneer
number seven
for her oscar-winning portrayal of
serial killer eileen wuornos in monster
charlize theron spent multiple hours
every day in the makeup chair to have
prosthetics and makeup applied to give
her a haggard and weather-worn
appearance
it's a remarkable transformation for the
south african actress especially at only
28 years old and is only aided by the
addition of a set of nasty rotted out
prosthetic teeth that had to be tacked
down into the actress's mouth every day
number six
robert de niro went all out to prepare
for the role of max katie in cape fear
stripping himself back to only four
percent body fat and having multiple
tattoos done in vegetable dyes that
would fade after shooting
he also and this one is kind of creepy
paid a dentist thousands of dollars to
have the guy go to town on his teeth
grinding them down in an uneven pattern
and staining them it's an undeniably
chilling effect but it came with a
second shocking price tag de niro
reportedly had to spend twenty thousand
dollars to have the damage repaired
after shooting
number five
here comes gary archer again this time
on martin scorsese's 2013 film the wolf
of wall street to get himself into the
role of the unscrupulous donny azov
jonah hill had archer build a special
set of acrylic veneers that could be
snapped tightly in over the actor's
teeth lending the character an
unnaturally straight shiny and tidy set
of teeth for shooting days hill
reportedly had a hard time learning how
to talk around the false teeth working
constantly to do away with a lisp
created by all the extra material in his
mouth
number four
is there any set of bad false teeth more
iconic than mike myers in the austin
powers series created as a collaboration
between the actor and gary archer these
gnarled and gappy teeth work hard to
create a particular stereotype of 1960s
british dentistry these teeth are also
among archer's favorites saying in an
interview the first set of teeth we
created out of the box was the smile
that everyone knows as austin powers
with the crooked teeth and the gaps and
the stains mike took those and really
made them famous
where am i
number three
leonardo dicaprio has always enjoyed a
reputation for being a good looking guy
starting out as a teenage heartthrob the
actor has spent years pushing himself
harder and harder as an actor
constantly finding ways to subvert
people's expectations of him
so it's no surprise that the actor chose
to give his django unchained the
wretched calvin candy a set of
nauseatingly bad teeth that helped to
sell the deep moral cavity at the heart
of the plantation owner it can't
possibly be a coincidence that
christopher waltz disguised himself as a
dentist right i'm dr king schultz this
is my horse fritz
[Applause]
number two
one of the most instantly recognizable
moments from the original the hangover
has to be ed helms popping his mouth
open in that mirror to reveal that huge
gap where one of his front teeth should
be
obviously the gap could only be created
by actually pulling a tooth but did you
know that all helms had to do was get an
implant removed turns out the actor had
an issue when he was younger where that
tooth never properly formed and didn't
grow in he eventually had the implant
done as a teenager and can get it popped
out when he needs to
what do we do now
number one
finally let's close out with another
really famous one heath ledger's
portrayal of the joker in the dark
knight ledger's joker is like a starving
wolf in the film skittish and jumpy and
chaotic but capable of exploding into
sudden bursts of violence to illustrate
the more animal side of the classic
batman villain ledger had his teeth
ground down and severely yellowed
and there you go 16 times an actor or
actress took their craft out on their
precious chompers my lateral sizers it's
gone okay okay okay we just need to just
calm down if you've got your own
favorite dental mess sound off in the
comments and if you have odontophobia
well uh
sorry and big props for making it to the
end of the video
thanks for hanging out with us here at
the things we'll see you next time